when you're developing an API you
probably thought about adding API
management to handle things like exess
control usage stats rate limiting and
developer portals this is especially
important when you're developing a
graphql API in graphql the end user has
control over the data they retrieve from
the graphql
API by sending a document containing an
operation and a list of fields they can
basically retrieve all the data they
want and this is important when you're
looking at rate
limiting when you want to do rate
limiting for a graphql API it's useful
to do a query cost analysis this is
where you would look at all the
underlying
services at your graphql API I'd be
collecting data from and adding weights
to those Services service a might be
a rest API service b a database and
service C is soap
API collecting data from the database or
the rest API might be more efficient
than collecting data from the soap API
by adding weights to these different
data
sources you'll be able to handle rate
limiting instead of looking at
complexity such as the query cost
analysis you can also handle rate
limiting based on an x amount of
requests
per second minute or
hour of course you can also do R Li in
based on the maximum complexity which
would be the complexity from your query
cost
analysis or by looking at the query dep
so this is where you will be looking at
the number of
fields and the nested Fields a user is
requesting from your
API another aspect is developer portals
a graphql API often comes with a buil-in
playground or Explorer called graphical
this will give users a way to interact
with your API and look at the graphql
schema but it's not a substitution for
documentation so by adding API
management you can handle
documentation usage
stats
and even Access
Control in this video we looked why you
might need API management for your API
for several reasons especially when
building graphql apis you need API
management to help you doing a query
cost analysis for your rate limiting
also API management will enhance the
experience for people building graphql
apis thank you if you like this video
and want to see more like it please like
And subscribe if you have questions
please drop them in the comments below